former white house physician ronnie
jackson is sounding the alarm on
president joe biden's health ronnie
jackson tweets out quote
i served as white house physician under
three presidents i've seen what it takes
physically and
mentally to do the job i can tell you
right now that the way biden is hiding
from the public is a major
red flag something's not right but in
fact
as far as the liberal establishment is
concerned joe biden's decline
is actually better than all right it's
preferable i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from stefan
teasler or tysler who says my sincerest
thanks to harry's razors
for inspiring me to grow a beard yes
i think harry's is doing that for a lot
of people if my inbox
and my twitter mentions are any
indication uh
for our discussion of the harry's razor
situation
you can check out yesterday's show
always
always really good to be prepared in the
ca
in case any sort of craziness happens
one great way to be prepared
is to check out ready wise ready wise
makes being prepared
simple and affordable order online and
have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep ready wise
products are proudly made
in the u.s of a when preparing ready
wise meals all you need
four cups of water the water doesn't
even need to be hot you just pour the
food into the water you stir you cover
after about 15 minutes the meal is ready
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch
eliminating the need for additional
supplies very
very important to be prepared in the
event of an emergency if the past year
hasn't taught you that
i can't help you man you gotta you gotta
figure these things out okay
this week my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com when entering knolls10
at checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 30-day no questions
asked return policy
so there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today
frankly though you're not going to want
to return it you just want that peace of
mind
makes you feel a lot better sleep easy
at night ready-wise r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com
promo code knolls10
to get 10 off we do not know what is
going on with joe biden
and it's always a little irksome i think
when doctors diagnose patients from
their armchairs rather than actually
meeting with them
uh and uh you know ronnie jackson is
in politics too so okay however we don't
need the former white house physician
to tell us what we can all see plainly
with our own eyes
joe biden is not the man that he once
was he would appear to be obviously
in decline and
for the liberal establishment that's
perfectly fine my interest
in the joe biden is falling apart story
is you know not not so much any personal
aspect of
of his own health it's really what it
means politically
which is that for for a government
for a political party that that favors
administrative rule that favors rule by
technocrats and bureaucrats
and lab coats like the exalted dr fauci
it's actually
a pretty pretty helpful advantage
to have a president who is willing to
defer
to all of the experts and the
technocrats
this is something that the left has been
pushing for now for over a hundred years
which is taking political decisions away
from the people and the people's
representatives members of congress
senators and even the president taking
those decisions away
from them in the constitutional order
and handing those decisions
to experts so you you had a ton of
democratic candidates
jon ossoff now a senator in georgia
and joe biden himself saying i believe
we should follow the science you know we
need to follow the experts
nobody elected dr fauci to any office
nobody elected any of these lab coats
so when you have the politicians just
following blindly whatever the experts
say to do
that is an inversion of the
constitutional order but what it gives
the left is the end of debate
because if you have a robust system of
constitutional government where we're
debating eternal questions and
how we can pursue justice in the country
and
you know what the ends of government are
going to be when you have that that
system
then you have a legitimate realm of
debate but when you say
no we're going to nix all of that we're
going to have scientific government now
you you totally shut yourself off from
debate no one is allowed to question dr
fauci dr fauci is allowed to contradict
himself
day by day and hour by hour that's
perfectly fine but none of us can ever
question the exalted dr fauci
at any given point in time even if we
hold views that two days from now dr
fauci is going to hold it is still
not our right according to the
prevailing liberal orthodoxy
to question him jensaki was asked about
about president biden's fall and she
she danced around the question just
checking on the president he
fell going up the steps to air force one
on friday is he doing okay
he's a hundred percent fine i don't know
if you've been up those steps they're a
little tricky sometimes yeah but
he's right i've not been up those um
uh then did he see a doctor did he have
to see a doctor over it
um i'm not aware of that being required
there's of course a doctor who travels
with the president any president of the
united states but
um i'm not aware of it needing uh actual
extensive medical attention okay great
and then on the border
of course um no was it no
well i i'm not trying to be there's a
doctor who travels with him he was
walking around as you all saw by the end
of the day
so i'm just trying to be completely
transparent he's absolutely fine
uh as he was on friday was this weekend
he spent the weekend at camp david
look i'm just trying to be totally
transparent and that's why i'm going to
refuse to answer your question
that the tell here of course is that
they say did did biden see a doctor
jen soccer a doctor i don't think it is
needed to see a doctor
so that's kind of a weird way to phrase
it did he see the doctor or not oh well
you know there there is a doctor that
travels
yeah right lady but can you just give me
a straight answer i'm just trying to be
really transparent here
there are doctors doctors exist
and you know those steps are pretty
tricky uh no
no they're not they're steps
all steps are exactly as tricky as all
the other steps
and they're tricky for different people
and uh
it is a perfectly legitimate question to
know about the health of our president
but it really doesn't matter
did joe biden do anything this weekend
he was at camp david
joe biden never needs to leave camp
david because the the real people
running our country are
technocrats and even the the libs know
this the liberals
admit this sort of thing there was a
video that was
it almost gave me a permanent cringe on
my face
you know when you're little and your
mother says don't cross your eyes or
they're going to get stuck that way
the cringe was almost got permanently
stuck to my face
when i watched a video from the the try
guys
about their favorite man in the country
guys he's like gonna jump on in like
one minute i know he's almost here i
have the participant window open and i
get to allow him to enter it's weird i'm
gonna be smiling because i'm just
excited to see him
some nervous energy he's a busy man he's
doing lots of
world saving we were 45 minutes early
okay ready i'm admitting him right now
here we go
hey hey hi hi guys how you doing hi
[Applause]
china's going to invade right is that
that's
the minute chyna sees that video xi
jinping should be like you know now
now is the time launch launch the tanks
because america ain't putting up a fight
anymore
that is really really embarrassing stuff
though in defense of these guys i guess
it's a comedy group that started at
buzzfeed i think basically they're the
voice of a generation
and not only in the sort of
less than masculine mannerisms and
but also in the in the worship of
of these technocrats i mean it's not
just the the try guys
uh simon schuster is publishing a
biography of dr fauci okay that
i guess sort of makes sense uh you know
at least it's plausible there have been
biographies written about less important
people
but it's not it's not an ordinary
biography
it's a children's book simon schuster is
really
releasing dr fauci how a boy from
brooklyn
became america's doctor
by kate messner illustrated by alexandra
bai
most important biographies don't have
illustrators to them
but a children's book is the absolute
perfect genre for a dr fauci
biography for two reasons one
fauci's career would not stand up to the
scrutiny of an adult biography
fauci's last year would not stand up to
the scrutiny of an adult biography
how many how many things has dr fauci
gotten wrong
just about this pandemic
how many times has dr fauci misled
the people intentionally by his own
admission
during this pandemic you remember early
on we don't even need to play the clips
anymore he says
do not wear a mask there is no reason to
wear a mask
masks do not do anything other than step
one or two droplets
do not wear the mask it's very dumb and
silly
and then about five seconds later he
goes of course you should wear a mask
but i told you not to so that the nurses
would get them
he ran paul said that he issues a lot of
noble lies you know that that fouchy
believes
he is the legitimate ruler he's crafting
public opinion and so
he's going to tell you things that he
knows are not true sometimes
because that's going to result in the
behavior that he thinks
broadly speaking would be better for
society he's a leftist
social engineer and so he
you can't trust any particular thing
that he says but you have to trust his
his wonderful wisdom perfect for a
children's book so you can craft that
narrative and also
because the left has a long-standing
interest in indoctrinating
children into specifically here the cult
of public health administration
and more broadly into the the cult of
administrative government where we give
up our rights and we just have the
the eggheads rule us we know that the
left is interested in that that's why
they've taken such an interest in
education
i detail this in particular in my book
which is coming out soon
unless it gets cancelled first
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available for pre-order now
the left knows that if you can get
at the children early enough it's much
easier to shape their views
of the world and that's why you're now
seeing all sorts of crazy left-wing
theories including this new gender
fad not just in colleges not just in
high schools or middle schools all the
way in elementary schools we've got some
disturbing updates on that
coming coming later on that that is what
the stakes of this are so we think of
you know this is trump versus biden
not really it's it was trump versus
the liberal establishment which includes
all the bureaucrats and the
schools and big tech in corporate
america which is buying into this in
many ways even worse than the schools
are
it's it's really not a battle between
these two men or even
two ideologies exactly or two two
political programs
it's a battle between two very different
visions of american government
that's it there's some fighting on the
right right now too about exactly what
vision are we crafting
but it is a separate vision and so the
the play here for the dr fauci kid
biographies is to indoctrinate
students not into one particular
candidate over another but into a vision
of american government that is
at odds with the traditional
conservative
vision and you know they're really good
at this you know i would put my money on
the left being very effective in these
campaigns
and when i am putting my money on stuff
i head on over to my bookie whether
you're a basketball fan or a fan of
sports in general
you know that march is time for bracket
season and with my bookie
there is no shortage of opportunities to
cash in participate in college bracket
contests with jackpots all the way up to
50 g's that's right
five zero zero zero zero or pick and
choose your spots
by betting the teams that you know best
tournament games championship futures
or in-game live betting if you want
action my bookie has you covered
everything from college and pro ball
mixed martial arts to entertainment prop
bets
on u.s politics that's where i'm a
little bit better you know
candace owens to win the u.s presidency
in 2024 is anyone going to bet on that
who would bet against that my bookie
really gives you the chance to take
social knowledge and turn it into cash
in your wallet play smart bet smart and
win
big sign up today at mybookie.ag
and use promo code knowles to secure a
deposit bonus up to one thousand dollars
and make sure you use my promo code so
that they know that i am the one who
sent you over there
the promo code is k-n-o-w-l-e-s
make sure you use that at my bookie to
claim your first deposit bonus
so you've got this giant liberal
establishment that has really
they've gained a lot of power by taking
positions of
of influence and now they're exerting
that influence who can republicans put
up against that establishment
president trump is a good person to ask
about this president trump appeared on
my friend lisa booth's show it's called
the truth with lisa booth what a great
title and he was asked about the future
of the gop
president trump had a very very
interesting answer
ron desantis is doing a really good job
in florida and
uh i think josh hawley has shown some
real
uh courage in going after big tech you
know they go after him josh is terrific
and
you know somebody that's been really
terrific is ted cruz so for the last you
know he
he and i had it out for a while actually
we were very close
even during the campaign and then he got
nasty the press would say
once the nest is going to start i said
don't worry it'll start
and then it got very very you know
rather violent and vicious
uh but then it simmered down and and
he's been great and
uh rand paul has been great a lot of
people
i mean really a lot of people have been
terrific
sarah huckabee is going to do great in
arkansas
notice in his answer he's he's not
saying yeah there are some republicans
but you know really me i'm the future of
the gop
he is actually giving credit
to allies of his and former opponents of
his
his compliment of cruz here i think is
really telling
because if trump did not have to
compliment cruz i don't know that he
would
they as he says they had a very tough
primary battle in 2016.
but he's saying no i think he's he's
actually just calling it like he sees it
he's saying yeah ron desantis he's doing
good stuff in florida
and hawley is doing some pretty good
stuff in the senate and cruz is doing
doing really great stuff and he he's
giving the spotlight over a little bit
to republicans that he sees
as being in the mold of of where he
thinks the republican party should go
and in that maga movement that
reinvigorated so so many republicans and
even brought over a lot of people who
previously would not have called
themselves republicans so is trump going
to run in 2024 that's the question
he's been really nice to these people
now so it seems maybe he's
actually going to help them out but but
ultimately he's gonna have to make this
decision
is he going to seek re-election trump
gives some hints here
that he may not if you don't end up
running in 2024 which i know a lot of
people
want you to we all want you to you know
if it's not you who is it so
some of the names i guess i just
mentioned uh perhaps
and uh and others and others i mean you
know there's a
there's a pretty deep bench uh we're
gonna i'll make that decision sometime
later but but there's a pretty
deep bench if you look at the polls uh
but they love the job that i've done we
had a 97
approval to cpac a 97 approval on
policies and
different things so he's leaving the
door open here
but that's a giant statement for
president trump to say yeah the
republicans have a very deep bench
if president trump were trying to set
himself up to run in 2024
he would seem to me would say yeah they
got nobody
i'm their only chance they have nobody
else could do the job that we did he
gets in there he says
look i did a good job people really like
what i did but
he's going way further than i can
certainly than i would have ever
imagined president trump to go and way
further than
a a lot of republicans would go if they
were considering running saying
there is a very deep bench he said
he's not saying a deep bench of bad
candidates he's saying a deep bench of
good candidates
like desantis like cruz like hawley
i don't know if hollywood i guess he
probably wants to run for president
certainly desantis and cruz
are in a are in a pretty good position i
think
that's impressive stuff makes me think
you know
sort of sadly i guess that president
trump may not run but he obviously still
wants to be a player he wants to direct
the party he wants to direct
the conservative movement speaking of
deep benches
we now have a very very deep bench of
people who want to enter our country
illegally
and they are all lining up at the border
in record numbers
and criminals are making an absolute
fortune off of them
traffickers are bringing in men women
and children across the border
it is now being reported that that these
traffickers
are making 14 million
dollars a day actually they were making
14 million dollars a day
in february and the situation has only
gotten worse
so they're very likely making even more
money than that
former tucson border patrol chief
roy villarreal is pointing out he just
recently gave an interview he pointed
out trafficking
is a multi-billion dollar industry
billion with a b and it's it's not
letting up any time soon
some of it's paid up front on a life
savings somewhere that is paid
uh once they arrive in the united states
and essentially their indentured
certificates
and they're working off this debt for
prolonged periods of times
so i mentioned his description here just
very brief description that these people
they save up it's their life savings
they give it to these terrible criminals
the criminals will send them through i
just recently i was in
dc last night we did an interview with
senator cruz on verdict where he was
describing some of
some of the violent vicious tactics the
child abuse that these these traffickers
commit
i mean really heinous stuff you can
listen to the episode for i i won't get
into it here
uh and and they do it to extort more
money out of these
desperate people that is a situation
that is being encouraged by joe biden
it's a situation being encouraged by the
democrats
because the democrats know that the more
people that they can cram into this
country illegally
the better chance they have of winning
elections because down the line either
through amnesty
or through the birthright citizenship of
their children statistically they're
very likely to get more voters
that way and if hr1
which scott walker calls the crooked
politicians act
if that is pushed through the house and
senate
then you could have millions of illegal
voters voting even before the amnesty
that's what they're willing to do to to
encourage
this horrific system
all of which now is is giving more and
more power to some of the worst criminal
elements in society
somehow though i'm sure this will be
blamed on white supremacy you know it
has to be blamed on white supremacy
because everything is blamed on white
supremacy these days
uh the the that horrible shooting in
atlanta the massage parlor
uh that was blamed on white supremacy
the anti-asian attacks more broadly
being blamed on white supremacy
there was some hit piece about me
there's always some hippies about me but
from one of the
media matters or one of one of the
leftist uh
attack groups saying that if you ever
make a joke
any kind of joke about the woofloo you
know you call it kung flui or lung pow
sicken or
or any of those sorts of chop fluid was
the one or uh you know
any of the other i'm sorry that many of
the very funny terms are escaping my
my memory right now but that that is
perpetuating anti-white
or anti-asian bigotry and white
supremacy and the thing is the numbers
just just don't show that
ryan jodusky has a great great piece on
this in the washington examiner
according to the justice department
27.5 percent of all violent crimes
against
asian americans in 2018 were committed
not by white people they were committed
by black people over 50
000 incidents in a single year and
a disproportionate to the percentage of
uh
black people in the country white
criminals and asian criminals
each accounted for 24.1 percent of all
attacks on
asians that year and so therefore asian
attackers and white attackers are
underrepresented
in violent crime
[Music]
relative to the their proportion of the
population
in 2019 asians made up 6.2 percent of
the population but commit
uh committed just one percent of the
violent crime and
white people 62 percent of the
population but commit 50
of violent crime so it's not to say that
there's any any one group is committing
all the violent crime against
asians but when you're talking
specifically about this issue of
anti-asian crime
it is very clear the issue ain't white
supremacy and
and the the idea of white supremacy is
being pushed uh
simply to have a uh a scapegoat simply
to have an explanation that would jive
with political correctness
even though it has nothing to do with it
there was a gal who took to tick-tock
as all of our brilliant philosophers do
these days and
she she made this point that i'm i am
sure is being taught
in corporate america in the schools
which is that
even non-white people when they commit
crimes can be doing so because of
whiteness just a reminder that whiteness
can still be the culprit
even if a hate crime is committed by
another minority
white supremacy has many mouthpieces
don't underestimate that
white supremacy has many mouthpieces
including all the racial minorities
attacking other racial minorities
because they don't realize that deep
secretly their motivation is their how
white they are
underneath their actual race and
motivations or something like that
uh doesn't make a whole lot of sense but
it's just the end of argument right
there
that gal is is not making an argument
and i don't blame her i'm sure she was
indoctrinated into this
uh through much of our culture this idea
that no matter
what the facts are you have to blame
whiteness
or the patriarchy and it's unfalsifiable
and there is no debate because there is
no
there is not one piece of evidence that
you could ever present
to someone espousing that argument that
would change
their mind about it the argument that
whiteness and patriarchy or whatever the
cause of all the problems
that is not the conclusion of people who
have been thinking about this issue
that's the premise that's that's the
hammer and therefore
every other problem in society looks a
whole lot like
a nail speaking of weapons
uh you should check out ben talking
about gun control
uh today he'll be talking about calls
for for gun control a mass
shoot that mass shooting in colorado so
go check out go check out
ben's show today also if you haven't
heard by now
candace owens has a brand new talk show
with us exclusively at dailywire.com
the full show will be available to daily
wire members only
candice also has a podcast that you can
listen to on apple spotify
anywhere else you get your podcasts the
candace podcast
features several breakout segments from
the full-length show
this includes interviews panel
discussions and her advice corner
the podcast is so good in fact that it
reached number two on the apple podcast
chart
just after the first episode so if you
need some candace owens in your podcast
feed
look no further head over to apple
podcasts or spotify
and subscribe today be sure to leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear and make sure you tune in this week
i hear that candice is gonna have
a really really terrific guest this week
so that's all i'll say but make sure
you tune in head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
the biden administration is trying to
downplay the crisis at the border
which many members of that
administration spent years haranguing
trump for
now they called trump's policies human
rights violations all that sort of thing
and then what does biden do he actually
makes those policies
much much worse and broadens them out to
a much much wider scale
so the only way that they can get around
this is by using euphemisms
they're they're trying to redefine
reality by redefining the words that's
why
when gensake slipped up the other day uh
and called this a crisis it was a big
problem
jensaki is is trying to refer to this in
the most measured term she can she's
saying that there are
children presenting at the border
now that the public is seeing some of
the images because the congressional
delegation provided
some photos and descriptions about what
they witnessed
children who are frightened and crying
over crowded conditions
now that the public has seen that is
that not
a crisis and what conditions or
situations what metrics would have to be
in place
for the administration to call it well
children uh presenting at our border
who are fleeing violence who are fleeing
prosecution
who are fleeing terrible situations is
not a crisis
okay hold on let's the the verb
presenting here is pretty strange
what what does that mean they're
presenting at the border they're no
they're
being smuggled across the border by
vicious criminals that the biden
administration is empowering
and they're often being abused along the
way
but fine let's mealy mouth language
aside she's saying
that is a very sad terrible awful thing
and therefore it's not a crisis
first of all where did i hear that this
was a crisis jen can you remind me where
i heard that this might be a crisis at
the border
there have been expectations set outside
of
unrelated to any vaccine doses or
requests for them
that they would be partners in dealing
with the crisis on the border
well all right it was jen saki we got to
circle back
to what jen said yesterday because
she admitted that it was a crisis now
she realized oh i can't admit that it's
a crisis because that really makes us
look bad so i'm going to say hey
you know if something's really sad then
that's not a crisis
it doesn't make any sense would you say
this let's say there was some genocide
you say that the gen how dare you call
the genocide a crisis
it's a very sad thing and it's a
humanitarian issue
yeah i guess that's all true it's also a
crisis
one does not negate the other
but they're not making arguments it's
it's like the tick tock girl that
that tick tock girl talking about
whiteness is going to be a spokesman for
the democratic party soon enough
or somebody espousing the same ideas
because they're not making arguments
they're just
redefining words or
and i'm sorry they're not mutually
exclusive
presuming their own conclusions right
this is this is what begging the
question means
it's when you assume as the starting
point the conclusion of your own
argument
so when people say hold on you know
disproportionately these crimes against
asian people are not being committed by
white people
but you're blaming it on white supremacy
so therefore
you have to be wrong about that if
disproportionately the people attacking
asians are not white people then
it it follows that white supremacy can't
be the root cause here
and what that tick tock gal said is
it is yeah it people
maybe they don't know it but deep down
deep deep down
it always it always is
white supremacy that's not an argument
that's just it's like a cudgel
that's just just like a robot could say
that just on and on and on you would you
could never
make any sense of it because they are
going to cling to that
to that belief regardless of the
evidence this sort of thing
is is especially true in the area of of
sex
the way that the left is presuming their
own absolutely incoherent conclusions
and they won't hear anything about it
there was a journalist
kate sozen who i had never heard of but
she came out and tweeted a couple of
days ago she said it is
totally okay to have debate and disagree
but there you go there's that butt that
but you know that butt is gonna negate
whatever she just said and it does
it's totally okay to have debate and
disagree but folks in media the term
biological males is a serious anti-trans
slur
you should not use it without noting
that biological males
is an anti-trans slur
this is what's happening i think this is
why you know harry's razors came out
and publicly attacked me and this show
and our listeners by saying that if if
you
question the current transgender
ideology
that you're condemnable inexcusable
these are views totally beyond the pale
and i think the reason that so many
people have reacted to that
and is why even we had to come out and
say look if you can cancel an ad
campaign
it's fine it doesn't bother us at all
but when you come out and attack us
for holding perfectly mainstream views
and you attack our listeners
then we have to speak up and i think the
reason people reacted so much i
there were even some people who wrote it
and said i don't even listen to michael
knowles but are you kidding me folks we
got to cancel my subscription it's
because they see
that the the window of acceptable speech
is being shrunk down
basically to nothing where now if you
use the phrase
biological male you're going to be
accused
of bigotry i actually in a way
agree with this woman's advice to not
use the phrase biological male
but i agree obviously for very different
reasons i don't like it when
conservatives use the phrase biological
male i think it's giving away the whole
debate
to the left i think it is a way of of
ceding ground
to the politically correct radicals and
i think conservatives have done that
for for a very long time often for fine
motives or maybe because they're being
clever in their arguments
but ultimately the effect of that as i
detail
in speechless in my upcoming book is
that we just lose ground constantly
there there is no biological male
as distinct from any other kind of male
there's boys and girls men and women
when we say there's a biological male
we're implying that someone can be a
biological male
but psychologically a woman no not
possible
a biological male but spiritually a
woman no it's not possible
there are ancient heresies that posit
this understanding of human nature
but they're just not true there it's
it is not possible that you're to or it
is not true rather
that your body and your soul or spirit
or whatever you want to call it
are totally separate they're not
human beings are a unity of body and
soul
the technical term for this is the is
hylomorphism
okay and it's it means we're not when
the libs say that we're just meat
puppets you know we're all just
matter whatever all our hopes and dreams
and loves are just they're just kind of
pistons
pistons firing off and it's really just
a chemical illusion
and delusion they're wrong and when
people say that our bodies have nothing
to do with
who we really are and that you know i
can be a guy but deep down
on some metaphysical level i'm actually
a woman they're wrong too
the the true view of human nature is
that we are body and soul
inextricably linked here on earth
it's not bigoted to say that aristotle
is not a bigot
saint thomas aquinas not a bigot the the
greatest
philosophers and people who have thought
about these questions
not bigots for saying that and neither
are you
for saying it but this crazy ideology is
really taking over there is now
a man who just won a woman's beauty
pageant
not just a biological male a man
because that's what he is cataluna
enriquez made history by becoming the
first
out transgender woman ever to win the
miss
silver state usa beauty pageant which is
nevada's largest preliminary competition
chalk another one up to the patriarchy
that guy beat all those ladies and took
their crown and took their tiara
that's progress for you folks uh now
because uh mr enriquez won the beauty
pageant he will go on to compete in the
miss nevada usa pageant if he wins that
he'll compete for miss usa and if he
wins that he'll compete for miss
universe
this is just wrong
it's i don't know how else to put it i
hope this guy has a good life i hope he
figures out
the problems that are are uh
plaguing him but the solution
to his problems is not to pretend that
human nature is other than it is
and the solution to his problems is not
to take tiaras away
from women competing in beauty pageants
and the solution to the
problems of men who want to come who
identify as women
who want to compete in women's sports is
not to take away the scholarships from
the women
and to take away the trophies from the
women it's to tell the truth
the underlying premise here is that
lies are compassionate and that the
truth is cruel and if we
if we tell these men who think that
they're women there aren't very many of
them and i think really it's just this
ideology is being pushed
more by cynical political opportunists
than by people who actually
suffer from this themselves but what
they're saying is if we
tell these men the truth about their
nature
then that will be an act of great
cruelty and so we can't do that and we
need to totally reorder society
and take things away from women and
pretend that the world is other than it
is
so that we can lie to these men because
that will be compassionate
lies are not compassionate and the truth
is not cruel the truth will set you free
this is now being pushed
on children there was this is the most
disturbing commercial i've ever seen i
have a little series on my youtube
channel
of woke commercials where we try to
guess what product the woke commercials
are selling
this one i wouldn't i wouldn't do as a
separate woke commercial
breakout video it's too disturbing for
that but we do have to cover it because
the issue really matters this is a
commercial from pantene
the shampoo company uh now
defending mainstreaming the
sexual abuse of children in a a
commercial
in which uh two lesbian women dress a
boy up a little boy up as a little girl
and
insist that the boy really is a girl
take a listen
[Music]
so you've got this woman blow drying the
little boy's
now long hair it's how you are seen
sawyer is an old soul she is our
spunky and creative kiddo
sawyer also happens to be a transgender
girl
so says the first time she was out
in the community wearing the clothing
she wanted in her hair and
she kind of was herself and that was the
first day where i saw her pause it right
there
pause it right there so first of all i
don't know how these
lesbian women came to have custody of
this girl
something tells me they didn't make her
the old-fashioned way i'm sorry see how
confusing this is
i don't know how these lesbian women
came to have custody of this boy that
they are now
dressing up as a girl and insisting is a
girl
and i am certain that they they did not
make him the old-fashioned way
this raises other political and social
questions
but what this woman just said is so
awful
this woman said yeah i took my little
boy out and dressed him up as a girl
and and and that's when she
was herself when we pretended that the
little boy was a little girl
that's finally when she was herself and
then here's the kicker
and that was the first day where i saw
her
where i so this woman is saying that
this
child however she came to be raising
this child
this woman didn't didn't see the child
when the little boy was still dressing
like a little boy
only when the little boy allowed this
woman to dress him up as a little girl
only then did this woman see
the child and accept the child keep
going
she has always been super gender
creative
pause gender creative she has always
been super gender creative so obviously
that's a term that doesn't mean anything
just
i suppose it could mean confused but
what do we mean always
from from the time that the little boy
was a very little baby
when the little boy didn't have agency
when the little boy
was so suggestible to all the all the
influences around him
was that him being gender creative or
was that
these women with a very radical view of
sexuality
imposing that view on this
young boy keep going it's been a big
part of her transition
once she told us that she identified as
a girl
she immediately wanted to grow her hair
out it made me feel good and confident
and it made my insides match my outsides
all right i can't take anymore pause it
there if you want to watch the rest of
the commercial you can though i wouldn't
recommend it
so they've got this this little boy and
they've put this little boy on camera
and said okay that's what you're going
to say we've got the whole
studio set up here talk about how now
your insides are matching your outsides
right this is this is not an organic
moment
you don't set up a film shoot
organically that's not how these things
are edited or cut this is a obvious
not just contrived in the sense that
parents and educators are contriving
you know indoctrinating views onto
children
but but even the whole film set here and
what is so crazy politically the reason
i mention
this is because it's all to sell shampoo
it's all to sell shampoo
if this is what capitalism is i'm out
i'm out get me out of there okay but of
course this is not frankly the word
capitalism is kind of silly so it's a
word that was popularized by karl marx
but i think this should show
conservatives who are waking up to these
questions now
that there are immoral things that can
happen
in the the free marketplace that free
markets are wonderful i love free
markets
free markets are a means to an end which
is a good society right that's what
societies are always pursuing the good
human flourishing and those markets can
be perverted and lead society down
perverse ends
these women what they are doing and how
they are abusing this child should be
criminal
this should not be legal they should be
in prison for this in a just
society and and pantene pro-v or
whatever the
you know whatever the product is should
not only be ashamed of itself should not
only be boycotted this sort of thing
should not be permitted i think a lot of
conservatives are waking up now
to say oh right we we love markets in
their proper place
but we need guard rails on society or
the society that we talk about we love
free markets we love big businesses
it's going to eat itself it's going to
undermine itself capitalism corporate
america is going to become
the biggest vessel for radical woke-ism
radical leftism that is going to totally
subvert the culture
unless we conserve something beyond low
tax rates
really really spooky stuff
speaking of weird sex stuff i have to
get to the most important story
of our of our day teen vogue
i have assiduously avoided reading about
the teen vogue saga
editors being fired and claims of racism
and
disism and that ism but
it actually shows us something about the
cancel culture
and these these kind of drastically
political visions that the left and
right are putting forward
so alexei mccammon was ultimately forced
out
over a series of anti-asian tweets
that she published almost 10 years ago
when mccammond was 17 years old
so now she's 26 27 running teen vogue
and these tweets come out of something
she tweeted when she was a teenager
and now she's losing her job because of
that i don't know what the tweets were
if they were jokes or whatever
certainly i don't think that adults
should be
going around you know flagellating
themselves for things they did when they
were teens and frankly even in their
early 20s you know when people are young
and doing
stupid things i just don't think that a
decade later that should that should
cost you your job
but she left she goes my past tweets
have overshadowed the work i've done to
highlight the people and issues that i
care about
issues that teen vogue has worked
tirelessly to share with the world
and so conde nast and i have parted ways
that's the first part of the story then
christine davitt who is teen vogue's
social media manager
she was celebrating this it seems that
davit was one of the
forces sort of pushing this idea that
the editor should resign
so david is now in some hot water of her
own
over tweets and social media posts
davit who calls herself a quote queer
fat
philip pinks femme in brooklyn
i i don't know i i know what like three
of those words mean
brooklyn i know what brooklyn is so
that's how she describes herself in her
instagram bio
she has some old posts up in which
she used the n-word the word that you
are not allowed to say it's like the
only word now in
the english language that you are not
permitted to say
she said it uh this is according to a
report from fox news that the uh the new
york post cited
she referred at least twice to a friend
who would appear to be white
as the n word in 2009 2009
12 years ago and the next year she used
that word
in a joke tweet so now she's got to go
too
she's got to go too everyone has got to
go too now
before i defend any of these people
which i
am not really doing or i'm doing so very
reluctantly i just want to point out
teen vogue is absolute degenerate filth
that should be cancelled
speaking of things that should not be
permitted into the hands of children
teen vogue right up there just just some
really
really helpful
journalism that teen vogue has published
we have a guide to sodomy
how to's tips and more how to do it the
right way
the right way you know one could say
many things about that
certainly however whatever your views on
sex i think we ought to all be able to
agree uh this should not be in the hands
of
like 12 year old girls or 13 year old
girl that's probably like a bad right
that's not a good thing
if you if you need a to show an id to go
buy a playboy probably you should have
to show an id
to buy this trash another article how to
get an abortion if you're a teen
it can be tricky
it should be tricky it should be very
true it should be illegal actually
and publications that give people advice
on how to do that should just
not be permitted it's not an abridgement
of the first amendment
to say that you need an id to buy a
playboy it's not an abridgement of the
first amendment
to say that you need an id to buy teen
vogue and frankly i think you should
maybe the age limit there should be what
like 72 73 something like that
in any case i think it's trash i'm in no
way defending teen vogue
however with regard to what these girls
are alleged to have done
i think it would be better if we lived
in a culture where people
did not lose their livelihoods and
careers for for jokes they made when
they were teenagers
i think that would be better who has
never said or done anything that they
regret
anybody ever tell a joke ever
in your whole life that if it were
printed on the cover of the new york
times
might not reflect well on you especially
in 2021
you ever do that any oh everybody oh 100
exactly every single person has done
that
ever tell a joke that maybe might be
considered in bad taste really oh every
single person
there's no end to this sort of thing and
the political point here is that
revolutions tend to eat their own
that's what they do they are like the
devil in this way i was just recently
rereading
screwtape letters by c.s lewis which is
this book
you know written by one demon to his
nephew demon about how to tempt people
and bring them to the devil
and something that you you begin to
realize as the letters progress
is that when when they talk about love
the love that
we have for one another and the true
sense of that word love is
willing the good of the other i
love my wife in a different way than i
love
a delicious hoagie i love a delicious
hoagie in the sense that i want to
consume
the hoagie and this this is the way that
demons desire and love it's it's a
it's a desire to consume not a desire to
will the good of the other
but a desire to to consume to eat to
destroy
that's how this cancel culture is going
to end up that's how political
correctness ends up
the whole point of political correctness
is destruction it's not about building
anything else up goes all the way back
to a line from karl marx where he said
that that radicals must embark on the
ruthless criticism of all that exists
critical theory developed largely out of
these schools of thought
now we talk about a lot about critical
race theory what's the theory the
theories to criticize you can criticize
anything you can tear anything down
the late philosopher roger scrutin said
it's much easier
it's a point that many people have made
it's much easier to tear things down
than to build them up
and the job of radicals is to tear tear
tear it down and the job of
conservatives is to preserve things
and to try to build those things up
again
that's what we are trying to do here and
our our ability to do that
is is being taken from us the idea
that we can debate and persuade our
fellow citizens
that idea is being constricted and
decisions are being exported to other
people because of theories that make an
idol out of
administrative government theories that
make an idol out of eggheads
theories that make an idol out of
economics for that matter and out of the
marketplace
in a way sort of the flip side of the
coin that you see
with socialists we can't do that we need
all of these things in their right place
and we need to be pursuing the good
justice the end of government as madison
told us otherwise
we're just going to lose the whole thing
i'm michael nolan's michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. today on the ben shapiro show
another mass shooting rocks colorado
joe biden continues to lock kids in
cages while keeping the border open
and democrats aren't done yet they're
calling for an end to the filibuster
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen